das eindringende kinder muss so letten
musst du auch spenden
ich persönlich stelle ich mich auch
diese fragen und wenn ich kann tue ich
war so dass ich würde natürlich das
leben des kindes auf jeden fall retten
und ich würde nicht auf meine outfits
aufpassen ich würde auch nicht denken
okay dann dann bin ich nicht vorbereitet
in die vorlesung also das leben des
kindes ist viel wichtiger ist wichtiger
als ein outfit und dann fühlt sich auch
wenn ich die möglichkeit habe auch
spenden weil man kann ein bisschen
überall elfen oder wenn man die
möglichkeit hat man muss sich
informieren musste das thema am herz
haben und es muss natürlich von ihnen
kommen vermerkt oder wenn man spenden
möchte und man will spenden dann macht
man es man muss nicht so lange überlegen
das kommt einfach von ihnen und es wird
gemacht